-I'm here with the one and only
Tariq Trotter!
[ Cheers and applause ]
We're about to play a game
of "Pictionary,"
but to do that,
we're gonna need some teammates.
First, joining my team,
he stars in the new Marvel movie
"Eternals," opening in theaters
this Friday.
Please welcome Kumail Nanjiani!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Wow!
-Hey.
-That's what I'm talking about.
Looking good, buddy.
That's what I'm talking about.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow.
-Me and you, bud.
Joining Tariq's team,
he stars in season five
of "Big Mouth,"
which comes out on Netflix
this Friday.
Please welcome...
-Amazing!
-...Fred Armisen!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes! Yes, baby!
Yes! Yes!
-Yes!
-Visualize, visualize.
-Visualize.
-We won. We've already won.
We've already won.
-Tariq, why are you doing that?
-See the victory.
-No, no, no.
-Yes.
-It's a fun game.
-Of course it is.
-Well, I cannot draw.
I'm not being humble.
I really cannot.
Can you draw?
-Yes.
-And he can draw.
We're gonna lose.
-We're in trouble, yeah.
-Yeah.
-That's okay.
-Wow. That's okay?
-Yeah.
-You're fine with losing?
-Oh, my God.
This is gonna be
very embarrassing.
-No, no.
[ Laughter ]
-Unless it's a Ninja Turtle,
I can't draw it.
-All right.
But that's good.
-Okay.
-If it is Ninja Turtle,
just point at me like this,
and I'll say Ninja Turtle.
-No, if it's a Ninja Turtle,
that's the one thing
I can draw.
-Oh, yeah exactly.
Then draw it. Yeah, that's
the one thing you can draw.
-That's the one
I don't need to cheat at.
-Yeah, darn.
[ Laughter ]
All right, if it's --
Oh, gosh.
-Ixnay on number 7
-Yeah, I know, exactly.
Everyone knows how to play
"Pictionary."
30 seconds on the clock,
we'll take a turn,
then we'll have a showdown
where both teams will draw
the same clue at the same time,
worth double the points.
May the best team win.
Fred, why don't you go first,
and, Tariq, you can sit there.
-Yeah.
-Tariq is guessing.
What number, guys?
-Five!
-Three!
-I heard three.
[ Audience shouts numbers ]
I heard three.
-Five.
-You think five?
-Yeah.
[ Applause ]
-This is an object.
-Okay.
-All right.
Here we go, timer's on.
Here we go.
Wow.
-Soft pretzel.
[ Laughter ]
-He's drawing the outline.
-Yeah, he's good at the outline.
-Condom.
[ Laughter ]
No.
A man -- A genie in a bottle.
[ Laughter ]
-Ooh.
-Uh...
Aladdin. Oh, no.
Time, a clock.
A clock.
A time machine.
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Good answer, good answer.
I like that.
Yep, yep.
-What?
-Wow.
-How did you get --
-That's unbelievable.
-We're connected.
-That is unbelievable.
Well done, Fred.
-Where's the machine?
-It's obviously a time machine!
-That's great.
-Yes.
-Wow. Thank you.
-All right, I'm drawing.
All right, what number
shall I --
Thank you.
[ Audience shouting ]
Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-What is it?
-Oh.
A person.
-Does that help at all?
-Yeah.
I'm gonna guess people now.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay. Ready for this?
All right, here we go.
Uh, uh...
-First of all,
that's not even your board.
Like, you're drawing on --
-No, no, no!
He's drawing for me.
It's fine.
I'm sorry.
-Okay, okay.
-You cannot distract him.
Start the time over!
-Okay.
-Go back, rewind.
It's, uh -- Legs.
Uh, it's -- It's a horse man.
It's a cow man.
Cowboy!
Cow in the latrine.
[ Laughter ]
Poop, pee, bathroom.
Outhouse man!
-What?
-Udder!
Milkman!
-Yes!
Oh, my God! Yes!
-Yes! Yes!
It's a milkman!
-Milkman! Milkman!
-Milkman!
-That's all right.
-Yeah.
-Wow!
-Nice. Whose turn is it?
-Wow.
-Yeah.
-Wow!
-Oh, my God.
-Great, great.
-Wow!
-Great, great, great.
-Look at that.
-Security, security!
-Tariq, you're up.
Enjoy your -- go, and thank you
again for playing.
-Cool, okay. Cool.
-All right.
-Good luck.
-Hey, good luck.
-Whatevs.
-[ Laughs ]
Go get them, bud.
-I guess it's my job
to get rid of this thing.
-I'm sorry.
-I'm gonna do this one
without looking.
Just from the reaction...
-No, no, the whole game --
-Based on reaction.
-The whole game works,
you have to by this drawing.
-Fred, what number?
[ Audience shouts numbers ]
-Let's go --
Let's go up to 2.
-All right, don't look.
-Whoo!
Mm.
[ Laughter ]
This is an object.
-Object.
-That narrows it down.
-It's a thing.
-Here we go.
Timer's started already.
-Apple.
-Yikes.
-That's too easy.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-That's so easy.
-Milk, milk.
-I can't believe
you don't know it.
-Apple cider!
[ Ding! ]
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Stop -- Stop bowing.
Stop bowing.
Stop -- Stop it.
Stop clapping and bowing.
It's so silly.
-I mean, just have some grace.
-Yeah, some gra--
Yeah, exactly.
That's not even your board.
That's your board.
-Oh, cool. Yeah.
-That's our point then.
-That's our point.
[ Laughter ]
Kumail, you're up, bud.
-This is the best apple cider
recipe I've ever seen.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, that is good.
-I cannot draw.
-I know.
Turtle -- we got this.
Hopefully, it's a Ninja Turtle.
[ Laughter ]
If it is,
he knows how to draw it.
-Hope for the best,
prepare worst.
-Which one is Ninja Turtle?
Which one?
[ Audience shouts numbers ]
-Eight.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Ooh!
-Wait. You feel good?
[ Laughter ]
In that face,
I can see confidence.
You look --
You did.
You looked confident,
and you looked like
you were into it and confident.
-It's -- Oh, it's --
It's an action.
-That does nothing.
-I mean, everything in the world
is an action.
-Is an action.
Yeah. Okay, we got this, buddy.
We have this. Trust me.
-Okay.
-We're partners.
We're in the zone.
-I'm trying to remember how --
Okay, ready?
-Yes, I am ready, yeah.
-Here we go.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
Thumbs up.
Okay.
Positive.
Two thumbs up.
Siskel and Ebert.
Movie review, fist pump,
two thumbs -- thumb wrestling.
Thumb war.
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-That's fair.
-Fair enough.
-Wow.
-Fair enough, fair enough.
-Wow, look at that.
-Be that as it may...
-Did I count the right number
of fingers?
-Wait. So here's the way
this is gonna work.
Fred, you're gonna draw there.
I'll draw here.
Both of our teams guess.
Whoever guesses --
-We're drawing different things?
-Oh, simultaneously.
-Drawing the same thing.
-Oh, we're the same.
-Same thing,
and whoever guesses it
gets all the points
and wins the whole game.
This one's 5,000 points.
-Okay, cool.
[ Laughter ]
Let's do it, let's do it.
Big league money.
-What do you think?
What do you want to do?
-I dunno.
[ Audience shouts numbers ]
What do you think?
Number 1, number 3.
-We're both drawing
the same thing.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh.
-Ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh.
Ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh.
Okay, okay, okay.
We got this.
-This is -- This is an animal.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, wait you're going.
Gosh, look how fast you are.
-Okay.
-Shark.
Hammerhead shark!
[ Ding! ]
-Oh, my God!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-What?! What?!
-Good game.
-That was fair.
-Wow!
-Good game.
-That was amazing!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Kumail Nanjiani, Fred Armisen,
Tariq Trotter!